thank you to be was this report relates
to the proposed name change a small
subdivision that went to the regulatory
committee the original subdivision was
consented in 2009 but was never
undertaken by the Dean developer a new
developer is now wanting to realize the
subdivision and has put forward a name
change I take the report as being read
and happy to take any questions Thank
You Darren are questions from counselors
Soper counsel in counselor Monroe sorry
madam Chia wasn't a question I was going
to move I thought there were no other
questions I was going to move and I was
kind of seeking madam chair and so with
all this moved and seeking the motions
on the floor I'll put the motion all
those in favor please just raise your
right hand against motion carries thank
you moving to item number 7 on our
agenda today which is the possible
governance structure I'm I take it that
everyone has read the report I would
like to let you know that it has been
brought to my attention by the seee that
we need some technical issues covered
around this particular report a Council
of Committee or a committee of Council
does not have any men date to change
committees and this must be done in a
full council full council level we has
worship would cheer and we would go
through the same process obviously with
the report so if if everyone is happy we
can call an extraordinary meeting this
Thursday
so there is a full council in a council
meeting in the Civic we are able to look
at this particular report may be the
most madam chair Thank You councillor
Soper anyone happy to seek in there
thank you I'll second it
thanks mr. Moy sorry to see mr. Lewis is
the any questions or discussion around
me I needed timing than the day we have
the e or T meeting that he live in a
clock later the net would suit me better
because I have a eye specialist
employment around about that time also
thank you I'm just going to see clear um
madam chair councils and usually meets
at 3:00 p.m. I would suggest to you that
3:00 p.m. would be an appropriate time
okay 3:00 p.m. on Thursday and in the
Civic Theater so that there is plenty of
room for distant scenes of those who
wish to attend and listen if anybody
wishes to join by zoom we can provide
that via large screen thank you very
much
none of the discussion or questions
around there so I'll move the motion
that we have an extraordinary meeting on
Thursday at 3 o'clock our to discuss
this particular report that way we are
following obviously the right rules
around any governance change if this
should be a governance change etc etc
and that will be done on Thursday enough
for council meeting all those in favor
just give me a wave thank you against
carries thank you in the last report on
the agenda today is the next steps for
the souther Museum and Art Gallery and
clear will speak to that report
thank you madam chair look the the
council heads there's a number of steps
set out in that report and the the past
the past history in relation to it I
think what is front of mind is that the
Swank trust board has endorsed the
proposal to transfer governance of the
museum to endure Carroll City as have
Safin district and Gore district
originally you were given advise that it
was unlikely that you needed to consult
with the community but you were planning
to consult on an annual plan and so the
suggestion at that stage was why not put
it in the annual plan as we know from
previous experience that the museum
instead of a heart of many in the public
you chose for a good reason not to
consult on an annual plan and asked what
does that mean for the museum I'm
putting that question back to you in the
sense of giving you some options that
you could either determine that further
consultation is necessary based on the
sort of feedback that you've had from
the communities that you work with them
or you might say that limited engagement
with friends of the museum who have been
vocal about their views on the museum
and the past and engagement with Erie
would be appropriate and that you
receive that feedback before you make a
final decision or you might decide that
no further consultation or engagement is
necessary that step is a step that you
need to determine the answer to before I
think it is reasonable to indicate the
you've made decision and you're going to
then ask your partner local authorities
to request their trustees their
representatives to work with the Smeg
trust board to modify this make trustee
to introduce a skills-based board to be
entrusted with the guardianship and
ownership of the collection I think you
should also ask
we being recognized as partners in that
modified trust deed and I noted when
going through the historic resolutions
that were the resolutions from last year
that there was a resolution from
September last year proposing the
disestablishment of this make trust and
as these things have moved on it would
be appropriate to revoke that resolution
so there it is in front of you I'm happy
to answer any questions are questions
counselors counselor are not in my view
I'm sort of thinking that we probably
don't need to go out to consultation all
the interest I ever hear about is just
when the museum is going to open or
close not actually the governance so I
think it to be honest as much as people
want to know about it I think they
already know about it so I'd be quite
happy to move this forward without going
pick up the public consultation clock
fully supported as well
I think that community were wanting to
get some traction on winning museums
going and what that's going to look
forward to governance issues is really a
simulation I agree with you on the
weight though he falls to do no further
consultation but as cleared quite
rightly says once we get to the stage of
setting up a new trustee that's when you
bring in some strategic partners around
me and others I think you can select a
counselor so peg counselor Pottenger
thank you madam chair
I just want to say I'm quite happy that
we don't need to go to consider
consultation even the suggestion of the
limited consultation that's my
understanding we have been consulted in
Friends of the museum already
represented on the transport is a Zev so
I feel the limited consultations already
unnecessary because they have had the
book and I would just like to comment
that on the introduction of our skills
I would see the skills of an Eevee rep
as being absolutely relevant to a
skills-based forward we would want
someone on the skills base board who has
particular expertise in the care of
Tonga and I I believe that even while I
agree with the request of recognizing
the partnership I also believe that it
would be essential on a skills-based
forward to have a reserved slot for
someone with expertise in that
particular area I think you cancellous
okay I can tell you that the Museum
Trust Board is looking at how they see
these skills base boards being made up
for the collection so I'm just referring
to the collection in that we have
absolutely made it clear that it's it's
just a standard that we would be
participating in every one of those
discussions is I would expect that to be
done in a council level also and I think
because they are represented represented
we had previously made it clear if this
helps that the advisory committee there
is an advisory board II we advisory
board to Smeg would stay with the new
board or the new makeup so they're
absolutely clarifies the a we as a
partner which is is critical especially
when you're referring to our collection
I come from a place of frustration after
having the souther Museum Trust Board
make it very clear what they felt should
happen and we've waited so long for this
decision to be made then I think like
many people just want to get on with it
and get it done so I excellently support
the move to not consult on the
governance but very very strongly
recommend there is some consultation
done around the collection I think
that's going to be the next hurdle that
that board would have to face
councillor Ladd blow in Pottinger no no
I'm fine thanks chief councillor potting
Joe
yeah thanks Tony absolutely moved
forward with the skills base forward I
think it is our call and it expedites
this whole process and the critical
thing is with a skills-based board
hopefully they are entrusted to make
calls on the collection because if we're
going forward to a storage facility I
believe there's a lot of stuff in that
collection that perhaps we do not need
and it's evolved over years so you know
I welcome the skills base board to
actually look at the collection we may
need new stuff but to look at the
current stuff we have and I may be
interpreting their role wrong but I
imagine the board would engage suitable
people to do that Thank You councillor
potting Joe and I can add to that from
this is this mag chair that we've also
made a recommendation that no elected
members be on that board either that it
is very much skill based and not
politically driven and I think that's
the best decision and to move forward
for the sake of the collection a
councillor up weeks thanks Tony
yeah I'm happy to go forward with
without consultation on this one I think
we have done a lot of consultation
around museum issues already and I think
that with this being really just
solidifying the fact that the council is
going to manage the museum which it
actually or essentially already does it
doesn't really seem like that much of a
change the question I have is in the
next recommendation that says the
council work with its local partner
authorities I just wondered whether we
could add into that local authorities
and the self and regional heritage
committee and I realized that they are
the same thing essentially because the
regional Heritage Committee is made up
of representatives from the local
authorities
the regional Heritage Committee is the
committee that receives the Heritage
Fund and distributes the money to Smeg
on behalf of that fund and so I think
it's important that that part of the
conversation in councilor Lewis was with
me at a meeting with him on Friday and
it was really clear that there's a bit
of uncertainty in terms of the regional
Heritage Committee about we're there
rollers and whether how they can get in
and be part of the conversation so I
think it would be great if we could
initiate that and include them in that
conversation
I think beaks and councillors okay
thanks madam chair if there was no one
else to speak I was going to say I'm
happy to move the recommendations with
the addition of the words just suggested
and the appropriate recommendation I
think it was important to hit myself on
regional here at which committee mention
thank you clarify are the
recommendations are that the report
mixtapes may be received and the council
note in thanks make trust board for the
endorsement of the proposal to transfer
governance and management of the
activity of the museum for invocation to
a core Department of M McConnell City
Council and that council to terms
further consultation is not necessary
obviously that comes to work with its
partner local authorities in request the
Smeg trust or to modify the Smeg trust
deed so is it here that you would like
that addition put before is after local
authorities yes and the self and
regional Heritage Committee local
authorities myself okay so are we I'm
looking for Michelle I think taking
minutes and we got there
I mean mint in there Michelle she's not
in your head great and obviously that
council request a we are recognized as
partners I'd like to move that we take
the request out here we are partners
anyway so council a recognize a we is
our partners
and now my chair can I just do can I
explain that the trustee is not your
deep to alter and so you need to request
the Smith trustees to recognize that
that's why the requesters the year that
makes sense thank you clear in the
council revoked the resolution from 24
September 2019 relating to the
disestablishment of the Smeg trust so
that's been moved I have a seconder
Thank You councillor Munster and just a
question clear before we go out what
happens now after we've removed this
resolution in relation to the museum
council takes back the activity we've
also got a development that we need to
look at I'm wondering if we can actually
put a wee bit more into this particular
report and add some recommendations
around getting a project team together
for the redevelopment of the museum and
just getting away bit more momentum
around this you know I'm fortunately
madam chair there is nothing in the
report relation to redevelopment so
effectively you have nothing to base any
decisions on you could ask for a further
report setting out the steps for
redevelopment specifically in relation
to the question about what happens next
is that I will communicate with Gore and
Southland and us that they talk with
their trustees their counsel or trustees
and that we meet with the Smeg transform
to get that moving for the change to be
modified and I will also ask and it's
not only recommendations but I will also
ask for to negotiate a transfer date
with the with the cement trust okay I
would like to add a recommendation if
the mover and seconder would commit to
that to have another report brought back
to Council to determine the next steps
forward around the redevelopment of
do I have a speak in debt or sorry the
mover and seconder hibi to do that yes
that's great counselor Craig did you
have a Christian I was just seconding it
if you were going to put it as a
supplementary okay EDX motion to the to
their recommendations please Michelle
I've got an idea
so with all of those recommendations now
on the table I'll put that to the vote
all those in favor say aye
against great things counselors dick
motions carried I mean that is the end
of our meeting this afternoon I'm happy
to move into public excluded if I have a
second over there Anna's just giving me
away hands up so I'm just gonna check
out if she wants us to do something I'm
just letting you know that we are
currently live streaming so if I'll let
you move into public excluded I'm just
signaling to you that I will need you to
wait for a little bit once that occurs I
thank you everybody
who's attending the meeting today live
stream Thank You staff and elected
members I'm happy to move we move into
public why did I have a seconder all
those in favor